THE AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING IS
BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS.
AND IT IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CARILLO CARE.
DATE HERE.
FOR A GRAYSON.
KAMLAGER-DOVE YES QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
RAMOS.
REVERSED HERE WICKS [inaudible]
MATHIS. ONE WE HAVE A QUORUM AND
WE ALSO HAVE THE CONSENT AGENDA
IS THERE A MOTION. TO SECOND.
SO WE HAVE A SECOND MOVIE
INSURGENT.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CARILLO HIGH
CARILLO ID.
THE I A FLORA.
FLORA AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE I FOR SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RUMORS RIGHT
FROM MOST I REQUEST.
REVERSED I WORKS MATHIS
THE MOTION IS PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED